hello and welcome to this video playing
new Kasparov okay let's see what he does
okay maybe she played the night of then
yeah if he's the new Kasparov I'm not
going to allow it but he could try okay
got the Russell Nemo
Mikey was not really all that great Wow
and you worried about f7 seems he isn't
Wow
it was really really awful for black so
do I take with the look now on d3 and
Bishop takes also make some sense well
if I take with the rook what is it going
to play Knight f6 problem
v5 Queen c7 something crazy yeah I can
do that and just take on f4 with the
bishop I mean that is what really okay
um yeah so Quinn age 527 tech check hmm
there is also a five that could be quite
interesting I can also just take doesn't
that it's okay
yeah the FL is just going to open up now
okay if seven is a pretty pretty huge
issue
so Queen age five now is a move for sure
on Bishop takes I think I just take it
25 I have Group G 4 I didn't really help
him all that much I think I didn't
didn't really look at the check all that
closely but I still cannot believe it
okay so look G 3 why do I have anything
better
probably not a rook to e3
oh I could have connection a
reconnection I hope it's my general
internet okay I don't know
mmm okay I think I have reconnected lost
a bit of time there I think not sure
yes oh the queen is attacked and it
should it should move then I take bishop
takes d5 next yeah here you can't think
of rook f3 but I don't think helps all
that much we cannot play I have this one
good for cap 3 I don't know what that
was anyway Queenie
hmm it is not that clear this is a bit
crazy but it is not all that clear it's
good it should be for here on the cards
it irritates me what is this sound
what is that Rin sound because well that
move was probably crap but I have to
investigate it sounds like something
mama stop it it sounds like something
from twitch it could be from another
scene in the OBS it's really strange
anyway stop it no idea I could disable
that maybe and switch the mydesktop
sounds off and I only have 34 seconds
yeah I don't know that's a really weird
the whole thing is it weird the game is
weird the sounds are weird
and Quincy one I don't know probably not
the best move I only have 34 seconds
that also sounds a little bit odd it's
my connection always or for what what's
going on here
this our black is probably really taking
so much time
yeah okay Bishop g4 I would achieve
three airplay
you should probably tell or this one I
can not much of a choice cannot move the
Queen to develop maybe it's got night
aged five on the cards take this chick
I'm not sure if this is really helping
taking ouch eight looks it looks
dangerous
I cannot really move the bishop
unfortunately how to do it you cannot
move it not sure this is this helps it
maybe as a wacky move yes he has the
wacky move
yeah no I can take actually sorry that
the desk sounds are offered this
bling-bling was completely irritating me
still irritated by the whole game
but now I'm quite clearly a piece up
without any anything special going on I
wanted to give me a little bit more
activity here with the bishop
if it takes twice 1/2 Queen g3 for the
Queen trade makes it a lot simpler still
a plate is really badly the opening was
like just lost for Blackie and I didn't
prove it yeah and then the opening I
mean I really did not refute what he did
and this is a fine if I this is really
really terrible for and then taking yeah
probably
I'm surprised that the engine justice
like on +1 that's really low I mean
black has no development he's weakened
himself
Tong's and it's not remarkable okay well
d3 is correct and g5 this may be really
relatively best I was going what in the
game but it's probably right because
otherwise it's you know it's even more
terrible and g3 probably is no best
remarkable it's just like 0.8 for
position that looks completely busted
remarkable yeah so g3 is probably not
not best so okay to take and the Bishop
f4 is not super convincing take take and
d5 is a good move ah yes sure I blended
that totally yeah of course now the
bishop is attacked and here I don't have
the g4 so yeah I'm pretty awful that was
a big blunder then the engine still
thinks Bishop takes f7 is good
just going for the kill now it goes down
in evaluation
it's remarkable that black is supposed
to survive this but seems to be the case
at least at this depth okay so here I'm
okay again and even even a lot better
okay 392 is stronger and here 94 was a
win oh my god
yeah that was a super weird game the the
the pauses the reconnect and I had the
odd sounds I'm not sure what this sounds
I mean it looks like something from
twitch but this is from a different
scene it's really strange it shouldn't
be be there at all I mean really weird
yeah so many many blunders him like yeah
probably this is the best but it's good
enough took it and I should play 94 495
yeah yeah it was a super badly played
game yeah I didn't have much time but I
get done with this and now I'm was I was
really winning yeah that was really hard
I hope you still got something out of it
even just see me seeing me being
completely irritated might have a little
bit of entertainment value thanks a lot
for watching